welcome to the live stream boy do we
have a lot to talk about today and a few
people noticing in the pre stream chat
that the title of the stream has changed
not once but maybe twice since the
afternoon when I set up this stream and
there is a lot to talk about I am indeed
going to be talking about what is now
undeniable confirmed in writing Trump
Russia collusion if you haven't been
following it I will catch you up and
tell you everything that's going on I
will also be taking questions and
comments a little bit about that in a
second and lastly and firstly in a sense
I am going to be telling you about I've
spent the last 48 to 72 hours exploring
a disturbing trend I've seen on YouTube
affecting progressive youtubers and at
this point the sort of impact of what's
going on to progressive youtubers is
undeniable and I'm gonna be talking
about that as well if this is your first
live stream by all means welcome we're
really live I'm really talking to you
live right now assuming it's 8:30 1 p.m.
Eastern Time on Wednesday July 12th of
2017 if it is any other time then at
this point it is safe to say I am not
actually live number 2 love getting
questions and comments from viewers
during the stream the best way to submit
those questions or comments is through
the super chat function which is the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window super chat questions and comments
will be read number three new members
and new patrons who pledged during the
stream will get live shoutouts and
thank-yous you can read more about
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership the coupon code
I voted 17 does work and you can learn
about patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show where you can make pledges
as small as one dollar
per month lastly obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned subtle trolling
probably won't if it's subtle enough
we do have moderators hanging out in the
chat room and monitoring it and they
have been fully deputized to ban people
as they see fit so what is going on
let's start with part one of the title
for today's stream progressive youtubers
under attack I'm going to explain to you
what's going on and when I say under
attack I don't mean in some kind of
conspiratorial insidious way where
individual people are attacking and
hurting progressive youtubers either in
the physical or in the real world what
I'm talking about is something that I
have figured out that is going on since
July 1st roughly since July 1st I've
spent the last 48 to 72 hours checking
in with a number of progressive
youtubers and here's the bottom line if
you're not aware of these sort of
pre-existing YouTube advertiser boycott
the YouTube advertiser boycott started
on March 31st and March 31st is
represented by the number two here in
this image that I'm showing you so first
several months of the year things were
going really well on YouTube and as
they're started to gain momentum for
this supposed controversy about YouTube
ads showing up on racist and offensive
videos we saw a sort of tightening up of
the YouTube ad algorithm which you can
see by the subsequently lower Peaks
between the numbers one and two in this
image and then at the number two which
was March 31st a Wall Street Journal
article had come out just a few days
prior and that article alleged it had a
screenshot of a coca-cola ad on an
obviously racist YouTube video on a very
small channel a channel with eight
hundred or a thousand subscribers this
caused YouTube advertisers to lose their
[ __ ] and threatened to boycott YouTube
as a platform and in result in response
to that YouTube turned on a far stricter
youtube advertiser algorithm
and at the number to the David Pakman
show YouTube channel was making
effectively nothing okay
we lost ninety-nine percent of our
revenue I reached out to YouTube
eventually got ahold of some very nice
people at YouTube who said this is
temporary the system is learning and you
should expect YouTube ad revenue to
recover and get back to normal now what
we saw between numbers 2 & 3 which is
from March 31st up to about I don't know
mid June for example no I'm sorry
mid-may is that we did see YouTube ad
revenue recover to about 30 to 35
percent of what it originally was and I
I genuinely thought at this point I
really believed it's it's going to
recover it probably won't be a hundred
percent but if we can get half of our
revenue back and make up the other half
from the audience we're going to be fine
and unfortunately I reported to you that
in the last couple days of June but
really since July first
there has been an almost total return to
the crisis levels and we haven't lost
all of our revenue but we've lost about
fifteen percent that's where we are
right now so a couple things this is
what we already knew
couple things I want to address one when
I talk about this people email me they
say David everything's fine
I saw some ads on your channel there's
two issues that are going on we used to
get a 60 to 70% ad rate on our channel
meaning for every 10 views six or seven
ads were shown that rate is now 30%
meaning we are getting fewer than half
the ads we used to get but here's the
real problem and this is the part that
I've been talking to progressive
youtubers about we are getting shitty
ads I mean there's really no other way
to say we are getting low quality ads if
you go on now I don't want to say I want
to throw anybody under the bus in
particular but if you go on some
particular more establishment YouTube
channels you will see what I would
describe as high quality ads this
includes companies like constant on
this includes premier premium car
manufacturers etc by and large I was
noticing as of July 1st our ad rate is
down to 30% and we're getting no offense
to any companies lower quality ads what
are called auction ads in the YouTube
system and I said that's kind of that's
kind of weird I'm gonna reach out to
some other progressive youtubers and see
what's going on and see if there's a
trend here and I'm not gonna name any
names I don't know who wants to be on
record with this stuff but what I can
tell you is that a lot of these people
shared their revenue data with me which
by the way is a violation of YouTube's
Terms and Conditions which so I'm
particularly not going to tell you who I
spoke to but everybody who I spoke to is
seeing the exact same trend that I am
they are getting anywhere from 25 to 35
percent fill rate on their videos and
they are getting low quality ads almost
none of what we would call high quality
ads these are called reserve ads in the
YouTube system I believe our channel
over the last two weeks has a one
percent reserve ad rate we used to have
about a 50% reserve ad rate meaning we
went from half of our ads being the best
paying highest quality ads to one one
percent of our ads and the proof is in
the pudding the revenue has effectively
disappeared now do I believe that
somebody at YouTube is specifically
saying let's flip some switch on liberal
YouTube channels to hurt them no I don't
think that that's what's going on what I
believe is going on is that there has
been a concerted effort from YouTube to
be as brand friendly as possible and
unfortunately this has led to an
algorithm that has disproportionately
impacted news and politics channels I
don't know that many conservative
youtubers so I couldn't tell you whether
they are being impacted in the exact
same way the two conservative youtubers
I spoke to over the last 24 hours say
things are down a little bit which often
happens at the big
new quarter we've just started the third
quarter of 2017
July 1st but they're not seeing the
cliff dive that I and many other
progressive youtubers are seeing now
does it matter if there's a political
bias here no it makes no difference and
again I'm not alleging that there is a
political a deliberate political bias in
terms of what's going on I want to be
super clear but the impact of it is the
same in other words if progressive
youtubers are getting screwed right now
because someone at YouTube doesn't like
progressive channels or because of the
algorithm that's been set up as a sort
of side effect it doesn't really matter
progressive youtubers are getting
screwed and I'm talking to a lot of our
colleagues who are saying you know if we
had lost half our revenue we could
probably make that up in six months with
a number of pledge campaigns if we had
lost two-thirds of our revenue as I
believed that we had maybe by the end of
the year we could make that up but if
we've lost as I am now seeing
eighty-five to ninety percent of our
revenue this presents a whole new set of
challenges and I am going to be staying
in contact with everybody that I have to
contact at YouTube these are all good
people who I believe want to help I
believe that this may be above their pay
grade and this relates directly to net
neutrality on the program today today
was the net neutrality day of action
something I'm hugely supportive of I've
been talking about I know a lot of
people say David you got to move on from
Trump Russia we can walk and chew gum at
the same time right we can talk about
the imploding Trump Russia situation
which I'll get to by the way folks
believe me I'm gonna get to that and
talk about issues and just this week
we've talked about health care we've
talked about Republicans lowering the
minimum wage and three or four states
across the country and we have talked
extensively about net neutrality because
there is a three-pronged attack right
now on programs like mine it is a three
pronged attack number one is Donny boy
Don Donald Orange Trump in the White
House who wants to open up libel
lawsuits to make it easier to sue media
outlets who wants to go beyond just
being able to charge leakers and
whistleblowers but he wants to look at
charge
the media outlets that publish
information that was given to them by
leakers and whistleblowers that is the
crossing of a very important line in the
media world that is that is number one
prong two of the Hydra that is the
attack on independent media is the net
neutrality attack we've got former
Verizon lawyer Ajit PI running the FCC
you've got Trump without even knowing
what net neutrality is he once said net
neutrality is the Fairness Doctrine out
of his mind without even knowing what it
is he's put in a team he's put in an FCC
chairman who now is working with his
team to undo net neutrality we need to
be regulating Internet service for
Internet service providers under title 2
of the Telecommunications Act as common
carriers the way we would a phone
company the Internet is now effectively
like the phone it is a utility that is
the second prong of the three-pronged
attack on independent progressive media
and the third prong is the YouTube
advertiser boycott which again as of
July 1st has led to what you see by the
number 4 here a complete and utter
implosion of ad revenue this is pretty
serious [ __ ] that we're up against right
now if it were just the YouTube ad
boycott to the tune of 50% revenue loss
ok we could deal with that if Trump
wants to start prosecuting publishers of
leaked information we could just focus
on that if it was only net neutrality
that was attempted to be rolled but
rolled back we could activate around
that the way we've seen people
successfully activate against SOPA PIPA
etc but we're dealing with a three
pronged approach here and as a result
what we're doing is we're going to you
right I mean we at this point we have no
other place to go
we have membership we have patreon and
we have Amazon okay you can sign up for
a membership at david pakman.com slash
membership if you care about benefits it
has great benefits we do an extra show
every day just for our members called
the bonus show we have a commercial free
audio and videos
just for our members and you can sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership a
few of you already have well i've been
talking and thank yous and shout outs
will be forthcoming if the normal prices
are too high which start at 6 bucks a
month or 60 for the year we've got a
coupon code which i'll tell you about in
a second number two patreon patreon is
you don't want to get involved with all
this membership stuff you don't have
time to watch even more content you just
want to support the work we're doing in
the context of this three-pronged attack
on on what we are doing
you can throw in as little as a dollar a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and i'll update you in a second as
to how that is going and lastly if you
ever shop on amazon.com by going to
david pakman.com slash amazon before you
shop you will be sending us a kickback
to the tune of five to seven percent of
your purchase okay so let's do some
thank yous first of all is membership
membership is at david pakman.com slash
membership you pick your membership
monthly or yearly you hit the red
sign-up button and on the second page of
the signup process you'll see the coupon
code field if you want a 40% discount
off of membership you get a hundred
percent of the benefits but you only pay
60% of the price you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 and on that note ped pedro's
eius has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership while we've been
chatting and rachel Naugle has signed up
on our website thank you to both Rachel
and Pedro and I will have more
thank-yous forthcoming as far as patreon
goes it could not be simpler you go to
patreon.com/scishow
you hit the read become a patron button
and that's it you can pledge $1 a month
you can pledge $100 a month you can
pledge $1,000 a month we don't currently
have anyone pledging $1,000 a month but
you could we have surpassed the 1700
patron mark and as I've said before when
we get to the 2,000 patron mark I've
committed to doing an entire program out
of our studio with my hair like this
which it's it's scary particularly to
kids but the audience seemed to like the
idea when I mentioned it so if and when
we get to 2,000 patrons I believe it's
more a matter of when not if we will do
an entire show in studio my hair will be
that way all right so that's what's
going on with the YouTube situation and
I will keep you posted on it and more
information forthcoming I want to talk
about Trump Russia before we do that let
me dig into super chat super chat is
available with the dollar symbol at the
bottom of the chat window first from
Jacob ball who sent the $2 super chat
saying nothing other than keep up the
good work Dave ROM Rammstein rules 16
cent to 10 Canadian dollar super chat
saying we need more presenters like you
David well things don't turn around
we're gonna end up with fewer presenters
like me sadly but thank you I appreciate
the support says ikan Alice sent the $20
super chat thanks for all your hard work
and peach be with you Thank You peaches
for everybody I appreciate the sentiment
I've never seen on a super chat goodwill
with fruit but I love peaches and peach
be with you says he Macarius 39 cent a
to Canadian dollar super chat keep up
the great work David cheers from Canada
thank you we love Canada I was just in
Montreal when was it
Memorial Day weekend so I guess it's
been like six weeks feels like it was
yesterday but beautiful loved Montreal
Julianne carrion sent a five dollar
super chat have you decided to sell the
David Pakman coffee mugs okay here's the
deal with the coffee mugs we sell david
pakman show coffee at david pakman.com
slash gear i've tried making cobb feffy
from it and it was ok as i mentioned on
the show it ended up being kind of
bitter but for espresso or French press
or Chemex it works fine so the obvious
thing is well if you sell the coffee you
sell the coffee mugs but the problem I'm
having is we I'm trying to source the
coffee mugs ethically from like an
American company and if I do that I can
get our cost below $15 and if our cost
is $15 in order for it to be worth that
we've got to be making a little
something on it particularly when you
consider the time spent ordering the
mugs and shipping them out and whatever
I can't really sell a $20 coffee mug I
don't think in other words I think a $20
coffee mug even if people understand
that hey it's american-made and whatever
I think a $20 coffee mug is a bit much
and I think it was $15 maybe even plus
shipping with our cost and that's just a
tough I've not made the numbers work so
far Julian but I am interested in in
doing the the coffee mug thing
sandanista sent a five Australian dollar
super check will you be debating Kyle
kuklinski on the topic of Trump Russia
he seems to have followed a che Goodman
and gone off the deep end I think I know
who a che Goodman is he I think at one
point he he's the guy I think I did I
called out for something on RT and then
he did like 20 videos about me don't
take that literally it might have been
like seven but he did a lot of videos
about me and I just had to stop it start
ignoring the entire thing because it was
wacky I don't know that there's anything
to debate Kyle about because at this
point I mean it's a question of how much
collusion there was not if there was
some the Donald Trump jr. emails confirm
that yeah there was a total collusion
intent to collude there was absolutely
no surprise whatsoever from Dartford
Donald Trump jr. when he was told that
this meeting with the Russian lawyer is
part of the plan for part of the support
that Russia is is giving to duck to your
father he didn't even react it he said
great I'll pass her name over to
security so there's very little to
debate at this point no good has sent a
five Canadian dollar super chat will you
be getting into LA to go on Dave Rubens
show soon I'm right-wing but glad to
support the show anyway I was just
talking with Dave Rubin a couple weeks
ago for a moment it looked like I might
have been getting to July to Los Angeles
at the end of July and we were talking
about doing something in a studio and
unfortunately it's not going to happen
and we've got it's just not looking good
because my first weekend in August I've
got a bunch of stuff going on and then
the second and third weekends in August
are going to be david pakman show summer
vacation and then that fourth weekend in
August I will just be back
and then we're already in September and
Labor Day weekend so I think I I want to
get to LA and I want to go on Dave Rubin
show but I think it's gonna have to be
the fall and by the way I really am
interested on that trip of getting on
with Joe Rogan and I don't know how to
do it because everybody who I know knows
Joe Rogan says listen I can't really
help you because everybody wants to be
put on Joe Rogan's show and my
understanding is Joe Rogan doesn't
really like public campaigns telling him
to interview someone if you go on the
Joe Rogan podcast website there's no
contact method listed so if anybody can
help get me on the Joe Rogan program
that would be a very solid visit out to
Los Angeles I could do the Dave Rubin
show I could do Joe Rogan and there's a
few other appearances that I could do
and I could visit my little brother who
lives out there so I'm looking forward
to getting out there but it's not going
to do it's not gonna happen in July lil
Missy bleah 1981 sent a ten dollar super
chat telling us to keep fighting the
hood fight the hood fight I'm gonna
assume that little Missy bleah meant the
good fight a kind cent a fifty Danish
kroner super chat saying in my country
Denmark I'm a right wing voter but those
views would make me a Democrat in the
United States thoughts on that I mean
you're basically right you're basically
right because the u.s. if you look at
elected officials and we've talked about
this I talked about this today because
Joe Scarborough from Morning Joe has
left the Republican Party or is leaving
the Republican Party to become an
independent and the views of Joe
Scarborough are very similar to the
views of someone like like them one of
the more right
Democrats Joe Manchin and increasingly
people like Joe Scarborough and John
McCain and Lindsey Graham are closer to
being center-right Democrats which is a
pretty standard thing than these
ideological extremists right-wing
Republicans and along those same lines I
am considered by American standards very
left when I visit my family in Argentina
I am basically the equivalent of Joe
Manchin there where it is I I'm sort of
like yeah I'm kind of left but there's
way more to the left there than there is
here so that that's I think you're
absolutely right there no good has sent
a to Canadian dollar super chat saying
Reuben could maybe hook you up with
Rogen he did with Sargon yeah I mean I
know that I I know that that happened
but a lot of people are asking Dave
Rubin to hook them up with the choro
ghen show and I her to try to sort of
chart my own path if possible okay let's
talk about the Trump Russia stuff the
Trump Russia stuff at this point you
know that I did a piece yesterday called
the left is devouring itself over Trump
Russia and it was about this infighting
that's developed to put it incredibly
lightly this infighting that's developed
among the left over the issue of Trump
Russia and there are those who criticize
me and say David Trump Russia is nothing
there's nothing to talk about there and
there are others who say David how can
anyone on the Left deny that Trump
Russia is a major deal and as I pointed
out yesterday there are people on the
Left who don't want to accept what has
now been undeniably confirmed by Donald
Trump Jr's emails which was there was
Trump Russia collusion the question now
is to what extent and was it illegal and
was the attempt to cover it up illegal
but there's no doubt anymore about Trump
Russia collusion some on the Left feel
that if they give credence to the
hypotheses about Trump Russia collusion
that it somehow
undermines Bernie Sanders for example or
that it implies that Hillary Clinton was
a better candidate than she was and
there's a few other iterations of this
and I talked about it yesterday and it's
all [ __ ] I mean there's there is no
I'm a Bernie Sanders supporter from the
primary when he was eliminated from the
primary I made it very clear that he was
screwed by the DNC I made it clear all
along the DNC was helping Hillary
Clinton I ultimately voted for Hillary
Clinton because she would have not been
nearly as atrocious as Donald Trump is I
mean it's just [ __ ] to even suggest that
it would have been the same at this
point is either dishonest or ignorant
depending on which camp you fall into
but Hillary Clinton my view of Hillary
Clinton as a weak Democratic candidate
has not changed if I accept that Donald
Trump's campaign colluded with Russia
that that doesn't change at all if I
assert that Bernie Sanders had a great
chance to defeat Donald Trump in the
general election accepting what is the
undeniable reality about Trump Russia
collusion doesn't undermine the
hypothesis that Bernie could have been a
better candidate than Hillary Clinton in
the national election and I think that
this is a totally false dichotomy that
we are saying that we are seeing this
infighting and this this black-white
view from some on the left and
fortunately a lot of our audience is not
doing that a lot of a lot of our
audience is writing to me saying David
you know XYZ person on the left is
unhinged about this issue you're right
you can walk and chew gum at the same
time you've been talking about issues as
well as what's going on with Trump
Russia and that that that's it right
yeah I think that any time that
progressives start getting into this
you're only really progressive if you
believe X type stuff
I think it's a real problem and and we
should be staying away from it
particularly when now there is no
denying whatsoever that there was
collusion between Donald Trump and
Russia I'm noticing a lot of people
talking about the fact that I am wearing
glasses today as opposed to my contact
lenses it's a little bit of a later
stream and I actually had a contact lens
fall out when I went swimming today so I
figured I'd put my glasses on these are
Warby Parker glasses Warby Parker is a
sponsor of the show
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS I got
these the same way you can get them
which is I went on the website
I picked five pairs they send me the
five pairs for free without a
prescription in them you try them on
you pick the one or ones you like you
send it back and then the ones you like
they'll put your prescription in this
particular set is called the Lyle if
anybody's wondering but a lot of
questions about my glasses yes I wear
glasses my prescription is I think -
2.75 with astigmatism by the way and yes
you can check them out Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS all Warby Parker
glasses are gender-neutral or call them
androgynous or call them unisex I
actually don't know that for sure but
for the most part I think I think that
they are I've not seen anything at the
stores when I've gone in for adjustments
that say you know men's or women's or
whatever the case may be okay let's see
let me do a thank you so at the
beginning of the of the livestream I
explained to you that the YouTube
advertiser boycott crisis ad pocalypse
situation has been getting progressively
worse over the month of July and I've
told you that one of the things we are
doing is talking up membership you can
get a commercial free all-access pass to
the show as well as the members only
bonus show when you sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code available that coupon code
is I voted 17 and I need to I need to
send some thank-yous because thanks to
many of you the urgency with which we
need to increase membership has been
heard
Rafael Gonzales has signed up for
membership using the coupon code during
the live stream Milton Merritt has
signed up Milton thank you
you are a tremendous person Kristin
McDonald has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership while we've
been chatting here charles sin has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership as
as Kenny Turner Kenny Turner thank you
thank you so much for signing up no new
patrons yet we have patreon patreon
started slow it took us a while to get
our first hundred patrons but we've
since achieved over 1,700 patrons many
of you contributing as little as one
dollar per month and I would encourage
you if you don't want to deal with the
membership stuff if you already are too
busy to even watch all the content we're
producing and you don't care about bonus
content head over to patreon.com slash
david pakman show and if if you can only
do a dollar do the dollar because if
everybody did that the problem would be
over I actually had this is kind of a
funny thing earlier this week we had a
letter on the program from a viewer
named Chris and Chris wrote in and it
was pretty aggressive it was sort of
like an attack on a lot of our audience
and I'm gonna put that letter up for you
here Chris wrote in and he said David I
hope you'll read this on your show this
is coming from someone who is a member
and a monthly patreon contributor I see
that the david pakman show currently has
three hundred and seventy seven thousand
eight hundred thirty-five youtube
subscribers and I'm amazed that the show
still has less than two thousand patreon
contributors and of course as I
corrected on the program that is fewer
then not too to bug Chris but I know if
I don't correct that my audience will
tell me I don't know how to speak
English Chris went on to say we as David
Pakman show subscribers should
collectively be ashamed I'm pretty sure
if even half of the David Pakman show
YouTube subscribers pledged a mere
single dollar per month the David Pakman
show would be flush with funds and in no
need of YouTube ad revenue whatsoever
come on people help maintain the flow of
real and accurate news you know the
thing is we don't need even half of our
YouTube subscribers to donate anything
if 5%
a 5% of our YouTube subscribers donated
$1 per month who gives a [ __ ] about the
YouTube ad boycott it's over it does not
affect us anymore we've now got three
hundred and seventy eight thousand
subscribers five percent of those is 18
thousand nine hundred subscribers only a
dollar a month from one out of twenty
subscribers ends this entire thing so by
all means please help out with those
patreon contributions and I will do
thank yous as we go on here through the
evening let me jump back into the super
chat okay let's see double X Jamaica
sent a five dollar super chat saying
your fake news because you disagree with
me just kidding and I hope you're why oh
you are on the drunken peasants again
glad to go on I've made it clear I'm
glad to go on they haven't asked me and
I don't know if they're interested in
having me back on but I would be glad to
go back on dum dum dum dum dum sent a
five-dollar super chat just to try to
get me to say [ __ ] and that's a very
very childish super chat so I'm going to
skip it game fire 74 cent the $2 and 29
cent super chat saying digging the
badass glasses David brand like I said
these are the Lisle frames from Warby
Parker if you want to try them for free
you can try them at Warby Parker trial
comm slash TDP s okay BJ hill has sent
the $5 super chat no question or comment
thanks very much says e canal is sent
the $20 super chat clarifying she meant
peace be with you rather than peach be
with you peaches were fine I had no
problem at all with peach be with you D
night sent a $2.00 super chat a
democratic platform 2018 Republican
cover-up I I don't know that I agree
with you denied and in fact I've been
pretty clear that
Democrats need a platform that is number
one United and number two not dependent
on what's going on with Donald Trump
Russia and possible Republican cover-ups
and no matter what happens with Trump
Russia Democrats need a platform that is
not just we aren't Republicans from
Republicans or Liars bad collude errs
whatever the case may be
and the reason why is simple if Trump
Russia disintegrates into nothing and
now we obviously have confirmed Trump
Russia collusion although we've not
confirmed its criminality we've not
confirmed the extent of it but we have
confirmed Trump Russia collusion now
undeniably Donald Trump jr. put out
emails minutes before the New York Times
was going to put them out confirming
that the collusion took place if it
evaporates and no charges come of it
Robert Muller the special prosecutor
comes out and says hey you know what
we've investigated and we found no
criminal wrongdoing for example if that
happens you're going to need something
other than talking about Trump Russia to
win in 2018 and or in 2020 I think about
the other side of the coin for a second
let's say undeniable criminality is
discovered it's crazy
what happened with Trump Russia the
cover-up obstruction of justice whatever
even if you don't think this is likely
imagine for a second that it happens and
Trump ends up resigning or getting
impeached what do you run on the guy's
gone how do you run on Republican
cover-up and Trump Russia collusion you
need a coherent platform no matter no
matter what I believe health care should
be at the top of that list
I believe that a more an approach to the
environment and by that I'm talking
about pollution fossil fuels climate
change etc an approach to the
environment that is not trying to bash
Republicans over the head with science
because you and I unless you're a hatred
you and I know the science already and
the science is not going to convince
anybody and in fact we've learned from
behavioral economics that bashing people
over the head with the facts often makes
them more more resistant to changing
their view we need a sort of
national security patriotic type
argument around the environment and
there needs to be some kind of coherent
broader national security message and
that includes in my mind Isis and
immigration okay and if Democrats can't
come together if it's just gonna be
arguments about you know whether we need
safe spaces or identity politics or
whether Trump Russia is really something
that should be focused on it's not gonna
be good it's not gonna be good so denied
those are my thoughts there Rodina
Redman sent a five dollar super chat hi
david ii super chat if you ever need a
bodyguard my cousin said 'i will be
obliged keep going black sheng facebook
group has got your back okay i've never
heard of that facebook group i'm
mentioning it because it's in the super
chat i want to make sure that you know
that i am not endorsing or standing by
anything there however I appreciate
Rodina anybody who has my back that I
think is is much appreciated and a very
very good thing so what's gonna happen
tomorrow on the show tomorrow on the
program we were going to be talking
about the paralysis and finger-pointing
that's happening at the White House as a
result of the never ending Trump Russia
scandal and it's so funny
for those who believe there is no
scandal so far no allegations made about
Trump Russia collusion have been
disproven none many have been proven
many are as yet unproven nothing has
been disproven yeah okay the P tapes
from the blackmail dossier may be
unlikely not disproven hard to prove a
negative we may never actually get proof
of those but the story is only growing
and the White House is paralyzed
Donald Trump has reportedly according to
aides been spending most of his time not
leaving the Oval Office tweeting very
little no on-camera appearances very few
on-camera appearances recently and now
he's off to Paris and the
finger-pointing is starting people are
talking about maybe rinse Priebus needs
to go Donald Trump's attorney mark as
awaits is reportedly not pleased that
Jared Kushner is speaking to
leeta Trump about Russia related stuff
and not keeping the legal team involved
it's all pointing fingers it's all
paralysis and in the meantime and this
is why this current sort of baseline of
scandal continues at being a good thing
who's talking about tax reform the Trump
administration is busy dealing with
scandals that could lead to anything
from criminal charges to resignations
for a whole bunch of people in the Trump
administration they're not doing tax
reform health care is close to dead
Mitch McConnell now is talking about
skipping half of their August vacation
to try to get health care done but the
plan is an absolute and total disaster
the Mexican wolf I mean the Mexican wall
that Mexico is going to pay for it's a
fantasy world at this point because of
the paralysis that's coming from this so
to that extent it's almost better for
Democrats for Trump to remain riddled
and scandal until the 2018 election for
Democrats and ideally progressive
Democrats not corporate the right wing
Democrats to make gains in the house and
ideally the Senate that might actually
end up being the best thing rather than
a very quick impeachment for Donald
Trump speaking completely hypothetically
of course all right there's a lot of
other stuff to discuss on tomorrow's
program and I'll tell you about some of
the other stories we'll be dealing with
we will have a discussion about whether
the Russian lawyer that now we know
admittedly colluded with Donald Trump
jr. or I guess the way to say it would
be Donald Trump jr. attempted to collude
with her there are allegations that she
was in the country illegally and how
ironic would that be given Donald
Trump's focus on undocumented immigrants
coming from mostly Latin American
countries and then of course the travel
ban for people coming in from
middle-eastern countries it's possible
that the lawyer we're still looking at
the data it's possible that a lawyer was
here in the country illegally we will
talk about more swamp filling a goldman
sachs banker appears to be the top
choice for donald
Trump to run the Federal Reserve not
exactly draining the swamp actually
quite the opposite I would say and many
many more stories including drug
resistant gonorrhea drug resistant
gonorrhea it's apparently a real issue
that we're going to have to deal with
let me do a couple more thank yous here
because we do have people that have been
signing up fast and furious while I've
been talking at david pakman.com slash
membership let me say thank you to debra
Liljegren Espinosa who signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the 40% coupon code
I voted 17 thanks to Doreen Fenton who
has signed up while we've been chatting
here big thank you to Anthony Russell
and Sean Whitney both of whom have
signed up using the coupon code getting
100% of the benefits at only 60% of the
price we are talking about this more
than before because of the YouTube ad
pocalypse situation that has completely
and utterly exploded in our faces as of
July 1st and this is something that it's
an issue that we are apparently going to
be dealing with as the new normal
at this point let's jump back into the
super chat the super chat from Travis
the human at the 5 US dollar level says
the Democratic platform should emphasize
restorative justice ok that's that's an
interesting idea
mean green-bean 88 has sent a $5 super
chat saying Russia used bribery it's
super effective okay that is an
interesting perspective and I thank you
for it and thank you for the for the
super chat support and on that note we
are going to wrap up this evenings live
stream I've got to get to research for
tomorrow's program every day is busy at
the David Pakman show thanks to
everybody who joined me sign up get
those patreon contributions in help us
get to 2,000 patrons doesn't matter how
much you can contribute
even a dollar a month helps patreon.com
slash david pakman show